What happens when you're figuring out life? Six form, uni, jobs, relationships, and you lose a parent. In this episode, we explore the often overlooked impact of grieving for key attachment figures in young adulthood and how it can shape who we become. It's a powerful and important episode and I hope you find it super useful. powerful and important episode, and I hope you find it super useful. Hi, welcome along to the Aspiring Psychologist podcast. I am Dr. Marianne,
当你在摸索生活时会发生什么？预科、大学、工作、恋爱，然后你失去了一位父母。在本期节目中，我们探讨了在青年时期哀悼核心依恋对象这一常常被忽视的影响，以及它如何塑造了我们未来的模样。这是一期充满力量且非常重要的节目，希望对你大有裨益。充满力量且非常重要的节目，希望对你大有裨益。嗨，欢迎收听《有抱负的心理学家》播客，我是玛丽安博士，
and I'm a qualified clinical psychologist. Now grief is a massive and important topic, and it's one we have spoken about before on the podcast, and it's one that's made me cry on the podcast too. Today I almost go there, but not quite, but crying is always okay, and it's important, and I love the idea of it's the love leaking out. Today we are taking a close look under the microscope
我是一名合格的临床心理学家。悲痛是一个庞大而重要的话题，我们在之前的播客中也讨论过，这也是一个曾让我在播客中落泪的话题。今天我差点又哭了，但其实没哭出来，不过哭泣总是没问题的，而且很重要，我很喜欢那种说法——那是爱化作泪水溢出来了。今天我们将用显微镜仔细审视
of grief, of losing a parent when you are kind of just getting started in your young adulthood and beyond. I lost my own father when I was 36, and I consider that pretty young. But of course I know I was lucky to hold on to him for so long. Not everybody is as lucky with their parents, but of course I also would have wanted to keep him for longer. So grief is a process with their parents. But of course, I also would have
悲痛，审视当你刚刚步入青年及以后的人生阶段时失去父母的感受。我在 36 岁时失去了父亲，我认为这算相当年轻了。但我当然知道我很幸运，能拥有他这么长时间。并不是每个人对待父母都能这么幸运，但当然，我也希望留住他更久一些。所以悲痛是一个过程，对于他们的父母。不过当然，我也希望
wanted to keep him for longer. So grief is a process we need to be able to work through. And of course, that yearning that comes with it where we want those ends of our lives to come back together and that key important person is missing. We are meeting today Hannah and Harry, and they are both working for It's Time charity which is a very unique charity which supports the needs of people who lost a parent when they were age 16 to 30. Let's dive in and catch up with them now and I will catch you on the other side. Hi, just want to welcome you along to today's episode. Hi, Harry and hi, Hannah. Hello, nice to see you again. Hello, lovely to be here today. Well, thank
能留住他更久一些。所以悲痛是一个我们需要去经历的过程。当然，伴随而来的那种渴望会让我们希望生活的两端能重新交织在一起，而那个关键的重要人物却缺席了。我们今天见到了汉娜（Hannah）和哈里（Harry），他们都在“是时候”（It's Time）慈善机构工作，这是一个非常独特的慈善机构，旨在支持在 16 到 30 岁之间失去父母的人群的需求。让我们深入了解他们的故事，稍后再见。嗨，欢迎来到今天的节目。嗨，哈里；嗨，汉娜。哈喽，很高兴再次见到你们。哈喽，今天很高兴能来到这里。好，谢谢
you for being here and I know lately there's been a lot of grief in my inner circle. I think there's been about four or five people in the space of about 36 hours who have died and what I'm learning is people often don't want to talk to you about grief. And sometimes people don't want to talk about grief. And so I really salute both of you for doing what you do and for being so happy to come and talk to us about it here today. Pleasure. It's completely agree. It's very taboo subject, which is one of the reasons why we set up the charity. It's time to break that taboo and start more conversations.
你们能来到这里，我知道最近我身边的人经历了很多悲痛。我想在大约 36 小时内，大约有四五个人去世了，而我所了解到的是，人们通常不想跟你谈论悲痛。有时人们就是不想谈论悲痛。所以我真的很敬佩你们俩所做的事，以及你们今天能如此高兴地来到这里和我们谈论这个话题。非常荣幸。我完全同意。这是一个非常禁忌的话题，这也是我们成立这个慈善机构的原因之一。是时候打破这个禁忌，展开更多对话了。
Completely agree and I almost feel like when I speak about grief it does help me as well, to process that grief as well. So I'm really excited to be here to help some other people as well. Perfect and I think sometimes people when they speak to you about grief and if it makes you cry, they're like, oh no, oh, what have I done? Run away, cheer them up, I'm awful, I should never ask these questions again. And I would say, that's just not the case. It's okay that somebody cries and you didn't do it, unless you did have a hand in ending that person's life, you didn't do it. But it's sometimes just really nice to be seen and to be validated and for people to talk to you about something that lots of people don't,
我完全同意，而且我几乎觉得当我谈论悲痛时，它实际上也帮助我自己去处理那份悲痛。所以我真的很高兴能来到这里，同时也帮助其他人。太棒了，我想有时人们跟你谈论悲痛时，如果你哭了，他们会觉得：“哦，不，哦，我做了什么？快跑，逗她开心，我真糟糕，我再也不该问这些问题了。”而我想说，事实并非如此。有人哭了是没关系的，又不是你造成的，除非你真的参与结束了那个人的生命，否则不是你造成的。但有时，能被人看见、被人认同，并且有人跟你谈论许多人避而不谈的事情，
actually. No, they don't. And I just wanted what you're saying about crying. It's like the emotions, there's kind of this thing of like, you know, don't embrace your emotions, but it's okay to cry. It's okay to feel anger. And I think a lot of the emotions you feel when you lose someone close to you are often quite negative. But it's right to feel those and share those and let it all out. Because if you don't, it only kind of gets worse. And so I'm just a big advocate of crying, you know, and letting it all out and having those discussions.
真的感觉非常好。确实如此。我只是想回应你刚才关于哭泣的说法。这就好比面对情绪时，人们有一种观念，就是“你知道的，不要压抑情绪”，但哭泣是没有问题的。感到愤怒也是没有问题的。而且我认为当你失去亲近的人时，感受到的许多情绪往往都相当负面。但去感受这些、分享这些并将它们全部宣泄出来是正确的。因为如果你不这么做，情况只会变得更糟糕。所以我完全是个哭泣的支持者，你知道的，把它都宣泄出来，并进行这些讨论。
Completely agree. And just speaking from personal experience, I didn't actually cry at all when my mum died. So my mum died at 17. And I wanted to be this really strong character that could get over it and just show people I'm okay. And it came back to bite me maybe about two, three years later. I remember looking myself at university into my room and I didn't want to talk to anybody and I found it really, really hard. So I'm all for you need to show your emotions, but I'm also all for that you might not feel that you need to cry. Make sure you just process it the way that you need to process it. And it's okay to feel what you feel when you feel it as well. Yeah, trust yourself to take it in stages really and come back to process the bit you need to when you get there. Yeah and it takes
完全同意。仅从我个人的经历来看，我妈妈去世时我其实一点都没哭。我妈妈在我 17 岁时去世了。我想成为一个非常坚强的人，能够挺过去，向人们证明我没事。而这大约在两三年后反噬了我。我记得在大学里把自己反锁在房间里，我不想和任何人说话，我发现那段经历真的、真的很难。所以我完全赞成你需要表达你的情绪，但我也完全赞成你可能并不觉得非哭不可。确保你以你需要的方式去处理它。而且你感到什么、在什么时候感到，这些都是没有问题的。是的，相信自己，分阶段去面对，当你到达那个阶段时，再去处理你需要处理的部分。是的，这需要
years, don't get me wrong, I lost my dad at 16 years old, this year the 20th year. And it took me a very, very, very long time to be able to speak about it. So whilst I say, acknowledge your emotions and talk, don't try and rush it. Do it at your own pace, as and when you want to, who you want as well. Cause you mentioned inner circle. For me, it took a long time to actually talk
很多年，别误会我的意思。我 16 岁时失去了父亲，今年是第 20 年。我花了非常、非常、非常长的时间才能够开口谈论它。所以虽然我说要承认你的情绪并多交流，但不要试图急于求成。按照你自己的节奏，在你想要的时候，向你想倾诉的人去诉说。因为你提到了核心圈子。对我来说，花了好长时间才真正能够
to my inner circle. I preferred the discussions with strangers because there was no real judgment there. There was no treading on eggshells and how I might be at a gathering with friends at barbecue in the summer. So thinking, oh, his dad's just died. I wanted normalisation in my inner circle and then to have this outer circle where I could be more vulnerable. And that
和我的核心圈子谈论这件事。我更喜欢和陌生人交流，因为那里没有真正的评判。没有如履薄冰的顾虑，也不用担心夏天在朋友的烧烤聚会上我会表现成什么样。我会想：“哦，他刚死了爸爸。”我希望在我的核心圈子里能回归正常，同时拥有一个外围圈子，在那里我可以表现得更加脆弱。而这
actually built my strength up to have the conversations with my inner circle over time. But when I say time, it's 10 to 15 to 20 years rather than six weeks after the event. 10 to 15 to 20 years rather than six weeks after the event. Yeah, and do you think some aspect of making it easier to share with the Inner Circle is that people then begin to experience their own griefs and so they kind of have more ability to relate or do you just think it's something about yourself and your development and your confidence or you're kind of developing more of an ease with that position? I guess grief is always difficult to speak about. And even here, it's difficult to speak
实际上随着时间的推移，建立起了我与核心圈子对话的力量。但当我提到时间时，这是指 10 年、15 年甚至 20 年，而不是事件发生六周之后。这是指 10 年、15 年甚至 20 年，而不是事件发生六周之后。是的，你认为让与核心圈子分享变得更容易的一个原因是，人们后来也开始经历他们自己的悲痛，因而他们有更多的能力去共情吗？还是你认为这仅仅关乎你自身的发展、自信，或者你对那种处境越来越适应了？我想悲痛总是很难谈论的。即使在这里，谈论它也
about. But I think as you grow in that grief and you learn from experiences, it does get easier. You never forget, but it does get easier to speak about and I'm how many years? Nearly 15 years down the road. So now I can have a conversation about it and not necessarily get upset, but in the initial years, the two, three years, 100% I would get upset and it would be really difficult to talk about and then I'll just forget about it and concentrate and procrastinate on other things. So I do think that as grief goes on and time goes on, it does get a little bit more easier. Yeah. And I think even from speaking to both of you today, one of the things with losing a parent earlier in your life is that there's more of a chance that before too long, the
很不容易。但我认为随着你在悲痛中成长并从经历中学习，它确实会变得更容易。你永远不会忘记，但谈论它确实变得更容易了。我已经经历多少年了？快 15 年了。所以现在我可以谈论这个话题，而不一定会难过。但在最初的几年里，即前两三年，百分之百我会很难过，谈论它会非常困难，然后我就会把它抛到脑后，专注于并拖延其他事情。所以我确实认为随着悲痛的延续和时间的推移，情况会变得稍微容易一些。是的，而且我认为甚至从今天与你们俩的交流来看，在生命早期失去父母的一个特点是，在不久之后，
years without them are more than the years that you had with them and I think that's quite a unique pain really. Yeah it is once you tip into that kind of halfway mark of I had more of my life without them than with them. It makes me feel a bit emotional actually just saying it again because that was actually a few years ago now and I think when you're a young adult so in the 16 to 30s and I was 16 so much of your life happens in those years and that's why like for me I was running away from it a little bit because you finish your A levels you you go to university, you then might go traveling and then you come back in your mid-twenties and then you start to
没有他们的岁月就会超过你和他们在一起的岁月，我认为这真是一种非常独特的痛楚。是的，确实如此，一旦你跨入那个分水岭——我生命中没有他们的时间比有他们的时间还要多。仅仅再次说出这句话，实际上就让我感到有些情绪激动了。因为那其实已经是几年前的事了。而且我认为当你是一个年轻人时，也就是在 16 到 30 岁之间——我当时 16 岁——你的许多人生大事都发生在这个年龄段，这就是为什么对我来说，我当时有点在逃避它。因为你要完成高中学业，你要去上大学，然后你可能会去旅行，接着你在二十多岁中期回来，然后开始
settle down, you then get married, you might have children and it all happens in that time. So that whole time I've been without my dad because yeah, he passed away when I was 16. And it is, is such a, I just remember vividly that that moment. And it was, it was really tough. Completely agree with you, Harry. And I, I remember there was a, there was a point, I think it was about two years ago. And so my mum was ill when I was three years old. So she was about 27. And when I hit 27, I was like, Oh, So she was about 27 and when I hit 27 I was like, oh my gosh,
安定下来，结婚，可能还会生孩子，这一切都发生在那段时期。所以整个这段时间我都是在没有爸爸的情况下度过的，因为，是的，他在我 16 岁时去世了。这确实是，我至今仍清晰地记得那一刻。那真的，真的很难。完全同意你的看法，哈里。而且我记得有过一个，我想大约是两年前。我妈妈在我三岁时生病了，当时她大概 27 岁。当我到 27 岁时，我想：“哦，
my mum was really young when she did initially get ill. And then I actually had a conversation with my dad a couple of weeks ago. And when my throughout the illness that my mum had, because it was from let's say 27 and she passed away at 43. So it was quite, it was quite a long illness. And I speak to my dad and I was like, how did you deal with this? Especially because I'm now 31 and at that age he was dealing with a sick wife and a young child and having to navigate life. And I was like, I don't even know how to have like, I don't know, like a pair of socks that aren't odd on. So it kind of made me understand and really appreciate how much my dad had also gone through and to really understand the magnitude of that as well at
我妈妈生病时真的非常年轻。”然后前几个星期我实际上和我爸爸谈过。在我经历我妈妈生病的整个过程时，因为那是从她大概 27 岁开始，一直到她 43 岁去世。所以这是一段相当漫长的病程。我和我爸爸谈过，我问：“你是怎么挺过来的？”特别是考虑到我现在 31 岁了，而他在那个年纪要照顾生病的妻子和幼小的孩子，还要摸索生活。当时我想，我甚至都不知道怎么拥有一双
such a young age. Yeah, and that really connects with me because I'm 43 now and I think it's only when you begin to get to ages yourself that you've seen your parents be at, or that they never got to, that you really have that insight. Because I do feel, I don't know, I still feel about 19 hanging outside the student union. But I know I'm not, but I don't feel that old. And I'm 43. Yeah, I completely know what you mean. It's also like the life events you go through. So when we had our daughter, I looked at my dad in a completely different way. So he then became a granddad and that triggered my grief
不是奇偶搭配错乱的袜子。这让我理解并真正感激我爸爸也曾经历过那么多，并真正理解在那么年轻的时候所承受的那种痛苦的分量。是的，这对我很有共鸣，因为我现在 43 岁了。我觉得只有当你自己达到了你曾看到父母所处的年龄，或者他们从未能达到的年龄时，你才真正有了那种深刻的洞察力。因为我觉得，我不知道，我感觉自己依然像个 19 岁、在学生会外面闲晃的年轻人。但我知道我不是，我虽然不觉得老，但我的确 43 岁了。是的，我完全明白你的意思。这也体现在你经历的人生大事上。比如当我们有了女儿时，我看待我父亲的目光就完全不同了。他成了一位爷爷，而这触发了我的悲痛，
because he wasn't just a dad, but he was a granddad to my daughter. So I grieve the fact that he wasn't there for those two roles. So I think you're, as you get older, and you embark on different parts of your life, the grief changes, it changes definitions, it changes shapes, it hits you at different times. And I often, I'm just so curious, like with my mom to be like, what was he like as a dad? Like, what did you do? How did you cope?
因为他不仅是我的父亲，更是我女儿的爷爷。所以我为他无法扮演这两个角色而感到悲痛。所以我想随着你年龄的增长，当你踏上人生的不同阶段时，悲痛也在改变，它改变了定义，改变了形状，在不同的时刻冲击着你。我常常充满好奇，比如对妈妈说：“他作为父亲是什么样的？你们都做过什么？你是怎么应付过来的？”
You had three children. I've only got one. All of these questions, like, how did he keep his full-time job and managed to juggle all this on the top? There's so many unanswered questions, but I'm kind of just glad I'm actually able to still ask them whilst I might not get the answer direct from that person. Um, I just get very curious of looking at it in, in different ways today. I think that shows you've got real emotional intelligence as well though,
你有三个孩子，我只有一个。所有这些问题，比如：“他是怎么保住全职工作，同时又设法兼顾这一切的？”有这么多未解的问题，但我只是庆幸自己现在仍然能够问出这些问题，虽然我可能无法直接从那个人那里得到答案。嗯，我只是在今天以不同的方式审视这一切时，产生了强烈的好奇心。我认为这也表明你拥有真正的同理心和情商，
Harry, that you are aware and mindful and curious and sometimes asking the questions is enough and we don't, we won't always know the answers, but once we've asked the question, we have the ability to answer it ourselves as well. And that can be really powerful as well. You know, you might be, I don't know how old your children are, but you might be bathing them or out on a bike ride. And you might be like, oh, well,
哈里，你有觉察力、懂得留心、充满好奇，有时候提出问题本身就足够了，我们并不总是能知道答案，但一旦我们提出了问题，我们就有能力自己去寻找答案。这也是非常具有力量的。你知道，你可能正处在——我不知道你的孩子多大——但你可能正给他们洗澡，或者和他们一起骑自行车外出。然后你可能会想：“哦，好吧，
this is what I think the answer is and that's okay. No, I was just gonna say just a second that one thing that my partner and he's helped me so much with grief always says and because I worry about when I have children and that they won't know that grandparent and he always says but Hannah they'll know her through you because you are her so I don't want to make you cry, Harry, I think that I think as you having a child, I think it's important to
我想答案应该是这样的。”这也是可以的。不，我只是想接着说一件事，我的伴侣——他在我悲痛时给了我极大的帮助——总是说，因为我担心当我有了孩子后，他们不会认识那个祖父母，而他总是说：“但是，汉娜，他们会通过你认识她，因为你就是她。”我不是故意弄哭你的，哈里，我认为当你有了孩子之后，重要的是
remember that your dad lives in you. Yeah, 100%. I just and this is, this is where it's so Greece really difficult, right? Because at times you think I'm alright I'm okay everything's fine and then just bam out of nowhere you get like a trigger of a different sensation a different feeling and that did come quite a lot when my my daughter was born like they have things at nursery where they like print photos of their grandparents and take them in and what makes me sad and will make me sad for the rest of my life is that
记住你的父亲活在你体内。是的，百分之百。我只是，这就是悲痛之所以如此艰难的地方，对吧？因为有时你觉得自己很好，我很好，一切都很好，然后突然之间，毫无征兆地，你会受到一种不同情绪、不同感觉的触发。当我女儿出生时，这种情况确实发生得挺多的。比如他们在幼儿园里会有这样的活动，让他们打印祖父母的照片带去学校。而让我感到难过，并且余生都会让我感到难过的是，
like in when my dad died it wasn't the era of smartphones and instant photos everywhere. And we meet a lot of people through the charity who share amazing memories of their parent or parents and some of the photos and videos are just, you know, quite beautiful when they have those memories. It is quite hard sometimes that you don't have the instant like photos and reels and reels and videos on your phone. But yeah, there are moments where, you know, the nursery asks for those kind of things and it is really difficult to, moments where the nursery asks for those kinds of things and it is really difficult to, a difficult moment. And everybody else in the cohorts probably got grandparents with grey hair, bald heads,
在我父亲去世的时候，那并不是一个智能手机和随处可见即时照片的时代。我们通过慈善机构遇到了许多人，他们分享了关于父母的精彩回忆，其中一些照片和视频确实非常美好，当他们拥有这些回忆时。有时候，没有手机里的即时照片、一卷又一卷的胶卷和视频，确实让人感觉挺不容易的。但是的，有些时刻，你知道，幼儿园会要求提供这类东西，这确实很难，幼儿园要求提供这类东西的时刻，确实非常艰难。而同龄班里的其他所有人可能都有着满头白发、谢顶、
glasses and your image of your dad might be quite different to that in that setup. Yeah, exactly. I mean, he's probably aged quite a lot now, right? It's probably got a lot of gray hair, but it like I say, it's tough. You can't really prepare for any of this you can think you're prepared, but there's still moments of where you get these triggers and you have to maneuver and pull on your mechanisms you put into place to help you through it and your mechanisms you put into place to help you through it. Such as in, and that could be crying, that could be going for a run, that could be talking, that could be doing some art, could be journaling.
戴着眼镜的爷爷奶奶，但在那种设定下，你对父亲的印象可能与此大不相同。是的，完全如此。我的意思是，他现在可能老了很多，对吧？可能满头白发了。但就像我说的，这很难。你真的无法为这一切做好准备。你可能觉得自己准备好了，但仍然会有被触发的时刻，你必须应对并运用你建立的机制来帮助自己度过难关，运用你建立的机制来帮助自己度过难关。
There's a variety of different things, but it is challenging and it always will be. But in a positive way, it's good to still feel that because that's still love and longing for that person 20 years later when they're not even here. If I didn't feel any grief or sadness, I'd be worried. But I do every single day. And that's just because of the... I just love him and I always will. Yeah, good. And I know when I watched, I have to confess I did watch the Harry and Megan documentary series at then. They were talking about Diana, you know, granny Diana, and they
比如，这可以是哭泣，可以是去跑步，可以是倾诉，可以是做艺术创作，也可以是写日记。有各种各样不同的方法，但这充满挑战，而且永远都是如此。但从积极的方面来看，能够依然感受到这些是好的，因为这仍然是对那个人的爱与思念，哪怕在他们甚至不在人世的 20 年后依然如此。如果我感受不到任何悲痛或伤心，我才会担心。但我每天都感受得到。这仅仅是因为……我就是爱他，而且永远都会。是的，很好。我知道当我观看——我得承认我确实看过哈里和梅根的纪录片系列。他们当时在谈论戴安娜，
had a photo of her and would take the babies over and talk to her and talk about her. And that was something I've always done with my dad as well, you know, keeping him alive and, you know, telling them stories about him. And I wish I'd asked my granny what it was like to have two boys because there was, in my family, there have never been two boys since my dad. But it's only that context that you begin to think, oh, I wish I'd asked that question because honestly, some days I'm like, wow, how did she do this? I guess she just sent them out and made them go and play. But yeah, introducing stories about them so that that becomes internalized in your own child's
也就是戴安娜奶奶，他们有一张她的照片，会带着宝宝们过去跟她说话、谈论她。这也是我一直对我的父亲做的事情，你知道的，让他活在我们的生活中，向他们讲述关于他的故事。我真希望曾问过我奶奶抚养两个男孩是什么感觉，因为在我的家族里，自我父亲之后就再也没有过两个男孩。但只有在那种语境下，你才会开始想：“哦，我真希望当时问过那个问题。”因为说实话，有时我会想：“哇，她是怎么做到的？”我想她大概只是把他们赶出去让他们自己玩吧。不过，把关于他们的故事引入进来，以便这些故事能够在你自己孩子的
mind about their character and the things they like to do and what made them unique is one of the ways that I get through. Is that something that you guys do? So perhaps you with your daughter and Hannah, your future spouse, never got a chance to know your mum in the present? I don't know which one of you might want to answer that, if either of you. I can maybe give a couple of examples. Not necessarily stories, but my mum was the best cook. I don't know whether it was just my opinion, but she was the best cook. No one could have beaten her. And I wouldn't say the word regret
心中内化，成为他们性格、喜欢做的事以及让他们变得独一无二的事物的一部分，这是我度过难关的方式之一。这是你们会做的事吗？比如你和你的女儿，还有汉娜，你未来的伴侣甚至没有机会在生前认识你的妈妈？我不知道你们俩谁想回答这个问题，如果你们中有人愿意的话。我或许可以举几个例子。不一定是什么故事，但我妈妈是最好的厨师。我不知道这是否只是我个人的看法，但她确实是最好的厨师。没有人能比得过她。我不会用“遗憾”这个词，
because I couldn't plan it, but plan for it. But I wish I had learned all of her recipes, her fried chicken, her, we're Caribbean. So her, the way that she does her Trinidadian stew chicken. And I've tried to reinvent for my partner and hopefully for my children to be in the future. But that's been quite tough because I know she was such a good cook and I really want my family to carry on. So I do go around to my auntie, who's her sister, and I learn her recipes because it's very similar and they learn from their mum and it's kind of been passed down.
因为我无法计划或预料到这一切。但我真希望我学会了她的所有食谱，她的炸鸡，我们的加勒比人。所以她做特立尼达炖鸡的方式。我一直试图为我的伴侣、也希望能为我未来的孩子们重新复刻出来。但这相当不容易，因为我知道她是个极好的厨师，我真的很想让我的家人将这手艺传承下去。所以我常常去找我的阿姨，也就是她的妹妹，去学习她的食谱，因为非常相似，她们是从她们的妈妈那里学来的，这种手艺就这样代代相传。
So that's something I try to do and something I really wish I had asked her a bit more about. Because when you're a 15 year old girl, 14 year old girl, who wants to learn how to cook? But now the 31 year old Hannah definitely wants to learn how to cook with her recipes. Do you find yourself like when you see it like on signs, do you find yourself ordering it just in case it's the one? Like so you can have them like this is it or this is it? 100% and we went to Barbados a couple years ago and there's a Caribbean dish, it's roti with, we actually say, instead of chicken curry, we say curry chicken and it tasted really similar and I do remember getting a bit teary and being like, oh my gosh, I haven't tasted
所以这是我努力去做的事，也是我真希望当时能多向她请教一些的事。因为当你是一个 15 岁、14 岁的女孩时，谁会想学做饭呢？但如今 31 岁的汉娜绝对想用她的食谱学做饭。当你在招牌上看到它时，你会不会忍不住点一份，以防万一这就是那道菜？好让你能尝尝看，心里想：“就是这个”或者“是这个吗”？百分之百会。几年前我们去巴巴多斯旅游，那里有一道加勒比菜，是烤饼配上……实际上我们不说咖喱鸡，我们说咖喱鸡肉。那个味道真的非常相似，我记得当时真的有点想哭，心里想：“天哪，我有多久没尝过
this in so long. So it's, but those are the memories which make me really happy remembering the house and the kitchen full of just the most beautiful smells. She used to make me breakfast every Sunday morning like a big fry up. So I try to live on a memory through those moments and try to carry those on as well. Yeah and any children you have in future, you know, I'm guessing Sunday mornings are going to be quite the occasion. Oh, of course it will be. Yeah. Lava fry up. You've made me really hungry, by the way, because it's lunchtime and all of that sound of food is amazing. Now, just I think for me, it's like, try and remember like habits and things that I've done at key moments like Christmas and New Year's. You know, when we grew up, my dad used to do like, you know,
这个味道了。”所以，这些记忆让我感到非常快乐，回想起那座房子和厨房里充满最美妙气味的日子。她过去常常在每个星期天早晨为我做早餐，比如一顿丰盛的煎炸早餐。所以我试图在那些时刻通过记忆活下去，并努力将它们传承下去。是的，你将来如果有任何孩子，我猜星期天早晨一定会是个大日子。哦，那当然会的。是的。超爱煎炸早餐。顺便说一句，你让我觉得好饿，因为现在正是午餐时间，所有关于食物的描述听起来都太棒了。现在，我觉得对我而言，就是尽量记住
getting the Christmas tree from a certain place, he put the star on the top of the angel and we've still got that angel, one of my sisters or I've got it, I can't remember off the top of my head. But then I grew up in quite a small village which was, it was really nice community. Granted, bad news travels fast, but there's a lot of people that knew my dad there and just being there sometimes is really nice just chatting about it and hearing stories. And my mom's like best friends with like his best friend still and all that kind of stuff. And it's really nice to keep in touch with all of his friends and see them at special occasions
那些习惯以及在圣诞节和新年等关键时刻做过的事。你知道的，在我们长大时，我爸爸常常会做这样的事，比如去特定地方买圣诞树，把星星或天使放在树顶上。我们现在还留着那个天使，要么在我的姐妹那里，要么在我手里，我一时记不清了。但我是在一个小村庄里长大的，那里的社区非常好。诚然，坏事传千里，但那里有很多人认识我爸爸，偶尔回到那里和大家聊聊、听听故事，感觉真的很好。我妈妈现在依然和我爸爸最好的朋友是好朋友之类的。能和他的所有朋友保持联系并在特殊场合
and special moments as well. You might not talk about it, but it's just like a underlying like nod of the hat. Like he's here as well type thing. Yeah, I totally agree. So are there any ways that if you're watching this and either you're a therapist or you're watching this because maybe someone you know has lost a parent,
以及特殊时刻见到他们，真的感觉非常温馨。你们可能不会特意谈论它，但这就像是一种心照不宣的致意。就好像他也在这里一样。是的，我完全同意。那么，如果你正在观看这段视频，无论你是一名治疗师，还是因为你认识的人失去了父母而在观看，
are there any ways you can be a really great friend or support to someone that's experiencing this? How could we hold their unique kind of needs in mind? So I guess just a couple of things that spring to mind. I would say don't assume, so your friend may be grieving and they may be showing signs of upset, being upset, being happy, etc. And that's just the way they're trying to cope. So don't assume that they're going to be upset and want to cry all day. So I think when you lose a parent, you just need a core group around you. And sometimes you might want to sit in silence. And that's okay. And sometimes they might want to go out on the down and
有什么方法能让你成为一个真正优秀的、能够给予支持的朋友呢？我们该如何把他们独特的需求放在心上呢？我想脑海中会浮现出几点。我想说的是，不要想当然。你的朋友可能正在悲痛中，他们可能会表现出难过、开心等各种迹象，这只是他们试图应对的方式。所以不要想当然地认为他们一整天都会很难过并且想要哭泣。我认为当你失去父母时，你只需要身边有一个核心群体。有时你可能只想静静地坐着。这没关系。有时他们可能想出门
have a drink. That's also okay. So I would just say, just be there for them. And if they want to talk about it, just let them and let them just talk at you. And sometimes it's okay just to listen and not have an opinion. So yeah, that was one of mine is just being here for them. Like just listen and they will I'm sure talk to you and just want you to listen. So that was one of my things. My other one is, is be normal, like be normal. Like if you're, if I've lost my parent and I reach out to a friend to be like, let's go to the pub, Just be normal, be like, you know, let's get drinks, go on a fruit machine,
喝一杯。这也是可以的。所以我只想说，陪在他们身边。如果他们想谈论此事，就让他们说，让他们向你倾诉。有时候，仅仅去倾听而不发表意见也是可以的。所以，这是我的建议之一——陪在他们身边。就像倾听那样，我确信他们会跟你交谈，并且只是希望你倾听。这是我的一点看法。我的另一个建议是：保持正常，表现得正常一点。如果你、如果我失去了父母，我联系朋友说：“我们去酒吧吧”，
let's play pool, be as normal as possible so it doesn't feel even bigger than what's going on in their head anyway, because if they don't feel like they can be normal in their own comfortable environment, then it will only kind of make things worse. And then the last one was, if your relationship with your inner circle,
请表现得正常一点，比如“你知道的，我们去喝一杯，玩玩投币游戏机，打打台球吧”，尽可能表现得正常，这样就不会让事情在他们脑海中显得比实际情况更大。因为如果他们无法在自己舒适的环境中表现得正常，那只会让情况变得更糟。最后一点是，如果你与核心圈子、
like your best friends is like super tight, in my view, don't be, let me know if you need anything, or let me know if I can bring something over. Go around, take them dinner, or go out, get them in your car and go for a coffee or go for a walk or go for a jog. I'm not saying be aggressive with it, but be like, I'm coming over tonight at eight o'clock, I'm gonna bring dinner, is that okay?
比如你的死党的关系非常铁，依我之见，不要说“如果你需要什么就告诉我”或者“如果我能带点什么过来就告诉我”。直接走过去，给他们带晚餐，或者出门，把他们拉进车里去喝杯咖啡、去散步或慢跑。我不是说要表现得很强硬，而是说：“我今晚八点过去，我会带晚餐，行吗？”
Rather than let me know if I can bring dinner around one night. That to me is kind of like, okay, yes, rather than, oh, okay, I'll let you know. And that's just my other one of be like, don't be so passive, but be like, yeah, you know what I'm trying to say. Yeah, I guess, you know, hold someone in mind, come up with practical ways that you can support them. I guess similarly to when people have babies, think, oh, I'll leave them alone.
而不是“如果我哪天晚上能带晚餐过来就告诉我”。对我来说，前一种方式会让人觉得：“好的，太好了”，而不是“哦，好吧，我会告诉你”。这就是我的另一个建议：不要太被动，而是要说——是的，你懂我的意思。是的，我想，把某人放在心上，想出切实可行的方式来支持他们。就像人们生孩子时一样，会想：“哦，我还是别去打扰他们了。”
It's like, actually, no, if you could come around and drop off some food, that would be ace. And if you could hold the baby while I have a shower. And it's just thinking about practical ways you can support that might also be emotionally comforting as well. And yeah, just even if you live remotely, distance from someone, I think it's always okay to regularly check in. And like you say, just be the biggest person you can manage to be and trust them to say if they don't want that or don't want that support from
实际上，不，如果你能顺便送点食物过来，那就太棒了。如果你能在我洗澡的时候帮我抱一会儿孩子就好了。这只是在思考能提供哪些切实的、在情感上也能带来宽慰的支持方式。是的，甚至即使你住在远方，与某人相隔很远，我认为经常保持联系也总是没问题的。就像你说的，尽你所能展现出最大度、最关怀的一面，并信任他们——如果他们不想要那样，不希望你提供这种支持，或者当时还没准备好，他们会明确说出来。但根据我的经验，悲痛有时会感觉像是一个非常非常喧闹的无声真空，人们最初会给予大量支持，然后就像无线电静默一样。我认为拥有悲痛经历的人通常更懂得如何去“打破常规”，但也不总是这样。就在昨天——过去几天我们在家里聊了很多关于死亡的话题。我们在聊天时，我正在写一张卡片，不是那种慰问卡，只是一张正面带有温馨留言的好卡片。我一边写一边变得情绪激动，我丈夫就问：“你为什么要做这个？
you or are not ready for that at that time. But I think in my experience, grief can feel like a very, very noisy vacuum of sound where people initially lots of support, then like radio silence. And I think having someone have grief experience does make them usually better at knowing that it's okay to kind of rock the boat, but not always. Even yesterday, so we've been talking a lot about death in my family the last couple of days. And we were talking, I was writing a card, not like a with sympathy card, just like a nice card with a nice message on the front. And I was writing that and I became emotional as I was writing it. And my husband was like, why are
你当时可能还没准备好。但在我的经验中，悲伤有时就像一个非常非常喧嚣的真空地带，人们一开始会得到很多支持，然后就像无线电静默一样。我认为，有过悲伤经历的人通常更懂得去打破沉默、触及痛处是没问题的，但也不总是这样。就在昨天——过去几天我们在家里讨论了很多关于死亡的话题。我们在聊天时，我正在写一张卡片，不是那种慰问卡，只是正面带有一条温馨祝福语的好卡片。我写着写着就情绪激动起来。我丈夫就问我，为什么
you doing that? Why are you sending that? If you died, that's the last thing I would want is someone sending me a card reminding me that you had died. I want to not talk about it. And I said, well, funny you say that because if I die, I would expect it to be like Harry Potter's letter scene in here. I would expect the cards to be coming through everywhere and I want people to come to my funeral and be really sad. I'm okay with demonstrations of grief. And he was like, well, I'll seal up the letter box. And I was like, clearly you've not watched Harry Potter recently. That doesn't work. They will come through the chimney. But people do grieve in different ways. But still, I'll seal up the letterbox. And I was like, clearly you've not watched Harry Potter recently. That doesn't work. They will come through the chimney.
你为什么要寄这个？如果你死了，我最不希望的就是有人寄卡片来提醒我你已经死了。我不想谈论它。”我说：“噢，你这么说真有意思，因为如果我死的话，我希望这里就像《哈利·波特》里的信件场景那样。我希望到处都是飞进来的卡片，我希望人们来参加我的葬礼时感到非常难过。我能接受悲痛的表达。”而他说：“那我把信箱封起来。”我说：“很显然你最近没看《哈利·波特》。那不管用，它们会从烟囱里飞进来的。”但人们确实以不同的方式经历悲痛。不过尽管如此，我认为我们还是应该做一些能展现我们是人类的事情，允许对方需要不同的东西，并允许他们告诉我们他们需要什么。我完全同意你的观点。我想起一件事，在经历了 15 年、14、15 年之后，我一直很感激的是，在母亲节或我妈妈的忌日这样的日子里，我的核心圈子、
Like, but people do grieve in different ways, but still I think we should do a thing which shows we are human and allow the person to need something different, but allow them to be able to tell us what they need. I completely agree with you. And I guess something that I've always appreciated 15, 14, 15 years down the road is when it's days like Mother's Day or the anniversary of my mom, my core group,
我最好的朋友们，他们总是会记得并给我发一条信息。这真的很有帮助。我就会想：“哦，他们其实一直记在心上。”这几乎会让我在那些日子里感觉好一点，因为我总是记得那些日子，但当他们也记得时，就平添了一份特别的意义。所以我真的很感激。
my really best friends, they always remember and they just send me a message. And it actually really helps. I'll just be like, oh, they've actually thought about it. And it almost just makes me feel a little bit more better on those days, because I always remember be like, oh, they've actually thought about it. And it almost just makes me feel a little bit more better on those days, because I always remember those dates, but it just means that extra something when they do. So I really appreciate it.
说到当有人——当父母刚去世时，真的很有共鸣。你刚才谈到当父母刚去世、一直到葬礼举行这段时间，其实你记不太清了，因为身边有太多人。但一旦葬礼结束，那些门关上之后，四周就会变得很安静，非常安静，你会觉得自己有点孤立无援，心想：“好吧，现在我该做什么？”我认为正是在这些时刻，去主动联系那些正在经历这一切的朋友或家人并向他们问候非常重要，因为那是段极其艰难的时期。
And just speaking about when some, it really resonated when you were just speaking about when somebody initially dies, when a parent initially dies, up into the funeral, you don't really remember because there's so many people around you but as soon as the funeral is done and those doors close, it's quite quiet, it's very quiet and you almost feel a bit alone and you're like, well, what do I do? And it's those times which I think is very important to reach out to your friends or your family who are going through this and to check in because that's a really hard time.
我对待失去亲人的人的一种做法是，当我在寄圣诞卡时——虽然现在已经不那么常见了，但我有时还是会——我知道特别是在失去某人的头几年，我会给他们写一张圣诞卡。我会把卡片写给住在那里的一家人，但我也会写上：“也怀念……”，这样他们的名字就会出现在卡片上。我听说这种做法非常受感激，因为他们并没有因为不再活在世上就不再是这个家庭的一部分了。当然，也要认识到他们在那个圣诞节或生日可能会度过艰难的一段时光，因为那个人不在了。哦，谈论这些事情真的很不容易，对吧？听播客的人大概能从我的声音里听出来，
Something I do with people who've lost people is when I send a Christmas card which doesn't happen this that often anymore but I will still sometimes well I know especially its first years without somebody I will write them a Christmas card and I will write it to the family who live there, but I will also say, and thinking of, so that their name appears in the card. And I've been told that's very much appreciated because they haven't stopped becoming part of the family just because they're no longer living. And of course, recognizing that they might be having a difficult time that Christmas or that birthday because that person's not there. Oh, it's hard isn't it to talk about this stuff. You probably hear it in my voice for those who
这些情绪自然而然地被调动起来了，但你知道的，因为这很重要。是的，这真的很重要。我想，正如我们刚才一直在闲聊时所想到的，人们有着不同的爱的语言，对吧？所以很多人会付诸行动，行动对我来说就是你向我表达爱的一种方式；或者有些人喜欢沟通交流；有些人喜欢肢体接触和拥抱；有些人喜欢手拉手；有些人喜欢礼物。悲痛在某种程度上也是类似的，当你在思考“我该如何支持对方”时，需要记住有时他们会想要什么？他们会希望我一天打三次电话问他们最近怎么样吗？不，绝对不会。但我是一个注重行动的人，所以我会说：“过来吧，我们来做这个。”我认为关键在于，在急于做某事去试着帮助别人之前，先退一步思考：那个人真正想要什么？
listen on a podcast. It just gets these emotional juices flowing, but you know, because it matters. Yeah, it really does matter. And I think the things that I think of as we've just been chatting now are people have different love languages, right? so a lot of people are going doing action, action is something for me that's your way of showing me like love or some people like the communication some people like the the touch and the hugging some people holding hands and some people like gifts griefs similar in a way like if and that's what needs to be remembered sometimes when you're thinking about how can I support the other person is what would they want would they would they want me calling them three times a day asking them how
我认为他们需要什么？试着找到合适的平衡点去帮助他们，不是一次，而是多次。我认为人们往往会急于求成，结果却适得其反。是的，刚才关于“爱的语言”的那部分让我联想到人们也有着不同的沟通风格。面对如何支持那些正在经历悲痛的人时，有太多因素需要考虑了。好吧，我只是在思考应对策略，我意识到一个人在孩子尚未出生之前就失去父母，从物理上来说是完全可能的，你知道的，一个父亲可能已经去世，而他们从未有机会见面。所以，我们谈论的年龄跨度其实非常大。我知道你们的慈善机构“是时候”支持 16 到 25 岁的人群。谈到应对策略，我接触过一些在小学或中学阶段失去父母的人，他们似乎确实更有可能在较早年龄尝试
they are so I wouldn't like no way but I'm an action person so I'd be like come over let's do this type thing and I think that's the key thing is try and try and take a step back before you rush to do something to try and help someone and think what what does that person want? And what do I think that they need and try and get the blend right to be able to to do something to help them not just once but several times. And I think often you can rush into it and get it very very wrong. Yeah and then just the love languages bit came into my head about how people have different like communication styles as well. There's so much that comes into
娱乐性药物和酒精，以此来试探底限、对抗体制、试图自我安慰或自我疗愈。我猜支持 16 到 25 岁的人群，这本来就是探索的典型年龄，但这可能会让人感到无依无靠，缺乏那些能够约束你、或者给你一个理由留在家中并得到培育和爱的稳定因素。抚养年轻人并确保他们的安全真的很难。但是，是的，我认为失去父母——这在伴侣关系破裂时也会发生——但父母的永久失去会在生活本就足够动荡的时期带来极大的破坏。如果我们能够做到的话，能不能稍微聊聊
it like when you're facing trying to support people who are going through grief. Okay I'm just thinking about coping strategies really, and I'm aware that it would be physically possible for somebody to lose a parent when, before that child has even been born, you know, a dad could pass away and they've never got to meet them. So, you know, there's a big span of age that we could be talking about. And I know your charity, It's Time, support people from 16 to 25. Thinking about coping strategies, my experiences of being around people who lost parents when they were in their primary or secondary years was they did seem to be more likely to use
物质依赖、应对方式，以及如何努力保护自己，并认识到我们真的不需要惩罚自己？我想当你刚才谈到这一点时，我确实很有共鸣。我妈妈于 2011 年 11 月去世——希望我没记错时间。我在第二年左右去了大学，我过得很开心。我几乎每天晚上都在喝酒、玩乐，当你第一次上大学并拥有自由时，你自然会这样。我非常不擅长跟我爸爸沟通，所以他经常对我很生气，因为我可能会有一周时间都不跟他联系。我想这部分是因为，第一，我在一个新地方，我有新朋友，我在大学里过得很开心；
recreational drugs and alcohol at an earlier age to test limits to act out against the system, to try and self-soothe or self-medicate themselves. I'm guessing supporting people 16 to 25. This is a typical age for exploration anyway, but it can leave people feeling quite untethered and without those kind of another stabilizing factors to kind of tell you no or to give you a reason to stay home and to be nurtured and loved. Like it's really hard growing young people and keeping them safe. But yeah, I think the loss of a parent, this can happen with separation relationships as well, but the permanent loss of a parent can be so destabilizing at a time when life is already destabilizing enough. Could we speak a little bit to, if you feel able to,
但第二，我从未真正处理过我的悲痛，当时距离我失去妈妈还不到一年。但这发生在大学里，那是一段艰难的时期。现在回想起来，我不后悔，但我确实很感激——如果我身边没有那些核心支持的话，情况可能会糟糕得多。所以我非常幸运，我有妈妈的朋友和我的阿姨们，她们几乎承担起了母亲的角色，确保我一切安好。所以，给任何正在观看这段视频的人一些反馈：如果你扮演着失去父母之人的母亲角色或父亲角色，去关心一下那个人吧。如果你能把他们当成羽翼下的人去照顾，他们会非常感激的。
substances, ways of coping, and kind of trying to keep ourselves safe and knowing we don't need to punish ourselves really. I guess when you were just speaking about that, it did resonate a little bit. So my mum passed away in November 2011, hopefully I've got that right. And I went off to university kind of about the next year and I had a great time. I was drinking every night and having fun but you naturally do when you do go to university and you've got freedom for the first time. I was really bad at speaking to my dad so he got angry at me quite a lot because I might go a week without checking in on him and I think that was partly because one I'm in a new place, I've got new friends, I'm having fun at university
各种物质、应对方式，以及试图保护自己，并意识到我们其实不需要惩罚自己。我想，当你刚才谈到这一点时，确实引发了一些共鸣。我妈妈是在2011年11月去世的，希望我没记错时间。大约第二年我就去上大学了，过得很开心。我每天晚上都在喝酒、玩乐，但这本就是你去上大学、第一次获得自由时自然会做的事。我不擅长跟爸爸沟通，所以他经常对我很生气，因为我可能会有一周都不跟他联系。我想这部分是因为，一方面我在一个新的地方，结交了新朋友，在大学里过得很开心
but two I had never really dealt with my grief, it had been less than a year since I lost my mum but that was at university and it was a struggle and now looking back I don't regret but I do appreciate that I'm it could have been so much worse if I hadn't had core things around me so I'm very lucky that I had my mum's friends and my aunties who almost took on that mother role and made sure I was okay. So just some feedback for anyone that's watching this, that is a mother figure of somebody that has lost a parent or a father figure that has lost a parent. Check in on that person. And I think it's very much appreciated if you kind of take them under your wing as well.
另一方面，我从未真正处理过自己的悲伤。那时距离我失去母亲还不到一年，但那是在大学期间，确实挺不容易的。现在回想起来，我不后悔，但我很庆幸，如果当时我身边没有那些核心的支持，情况可能会糟糕得多。所以我非常幸运，有妈妈的朋友和阿姨们几乎承担起了母亲的角色，确保我一切都好。所以，给看节目的任何人——那些失去了父母的孩子的母亲形象或父亲形象——提个醒：多关心一下那个人。如果你能把他们纳入你的羽翼之下照顾他们，我想他们会非常感激的。
I had a core set of friends as well, who always checked in and we mentioned that a bit earlier. So I would say, I don't think you're ever gonna get away with trying to try and push in barriers when your parent dies, but I do think that the community that you have around you can certainly help you and help you deal with it in a better way. I was 16 years old when my dad died.
我也有几个核心朋友，他们总是关心我，我们刚才也稍微提到过。所以我想说，当父母去世时，你永远无法轻易冲破重重阻碍，但我认为你身边的社区肯定能帮助你，并帮你以更好的方式应对它。我爸爸去世时我16岁。
And yeah, I kind of was in a similar place in my life where I went to university. I had a good few years there. I was very, very lucky to have an incredible group of friends there which made it a lot easier. There was a lot of partying. And I've seen, I personally haven't ever done any drug abuse or anything like that. I wasn't part of my grief journey,
是的，我当时的人生阶段也差不多，我去上大学了。在那里的几年过得不错。我很幸运，那里有一群非常了不起的朋友，这让生活轻松了许多。有很多派对。据我所知，我个人从来没有沾染过任何药物滥用之类的事情。那不是我的悲伤之旅的一部分，
but I've seen and spoke to people who it has been and I think a lot of those people feel it's the solution at the time because of the short-term benefit it can bring but it's definitely not the longer-term benefit to help them in their place and I think I don't advise it, I never would. But there's a lot more accessibility and availability of that longer term support in today's world. I think back to when I was at uni in 2007, I don't think there was really the welfare areas, there wasn't the more mental health availability
但我见过也跟一些经历过的人聊过，我认为许多人当时觉得那是解决方案，因为它们能带来短期利益，但从长远来看，绝对无助于让他们重回正轨，而且我认为我不建议这样做，永远不会。不过，在当今世界，这种长期支持的可及性和可用性要高得多。回想2007年我上大学的时候，我觉得当时并没有真正的福利区，也没有那么多的心理健康资源
of different options that students could go and get. So I think that with what is available in today's world, even social media brings, bring yes, there's a lot of negatives to it. But one of our main things is people being able to relate with a lot of social media stuff that we do at the charity. And I think sometimes, even if you lost a parent at five and you were now 25, there's things that you see and find online which gives you a little bit of a comfort blanket to maybe take a bit of a step in the door or even liking a social media post. It feels like you're part of something and I think back in the
供学生选择和寻求。所以我觉得，凭借当今世界所拥有的资源，甚至是社交媒体带来的资源——是的，它有很多消极的一面。但我们的主要作用之一，就是让人们能够与我们在慈善机构开展的许多社交媒体内容产生共鸣。有时候，即使你在5岁时失去了一位父母，而你现在25岁了，你在网上看到和发现的一些东西也能给你带来一点安慰毯效应，让你有勇气迈出第一步，甚至只是点赞一个社交媒体帖子。这会让你觉得你是某个集体的一部分，我觉得在过去
day that wasn't really a thing so I think having that is a little bit of a comfort blanket for people to feel like they are part of a community. And it just built confidence for them to take steps into communicating more with other people, joining future events, sharing their story. But yeah, it is super difficult at the time, especially when you're in that short term mindset of thinking that nothing is going to ever make this better.
这并不是真的一回事，所以拥有这些就像是一个给人们的舒适毯，让他们觉得他们是社区的一部分。这只是建立他们的信心，让他们迈出步伐，与其他人更多地交流，参加未来的活动，分享他们的故事。但是，是的，当时真的超级困难，尤其是当你处于那种短期的心态中，认为没有什么能让这一切变得更好时。
So I would take any opportunity I can get to try, but sometimes those choices aren't the right ones. And what I would say is speaking as a clinical psychologist who does lots of trauma work and does lots of grief work is that, yeah, it doesn't necessarily make it better. It doesn't kind of gaslight us into forgetting that it happened, but if we can work through any trauma aspects of this, using a therapy such as EMDR, so eye movement desensitization and reprocessing,
所以我会抓住任何能尝试的机会，但有时那些选择并不对。作为一名做过大量创伤工作和悲伤工作的临床心理学家，我想说的是，这并不一定能让情况变好。它不会像煤气灯操纵那样让我们忘记它发生过，但如果我们能通过诸如EMDR（眼动脱敏再加工）之类的疗法来解决其中的任何创伤方面，
it means that the trauma elements lay flat so that we can think about those without tripping over them. Then we're just left with the grief elements, which many of my clients tell me they're all right with. Actually, they want to hold on to the grief. They don't want to hold on to the trauma. If you've lost a parent in sudden circumstances, you may even have been there. You may have witnessed it. You may have had to get involved in CPR or if you've witnessed somebody become very unwell. All of those things can be traumatic in themselves. And sometimes even how we get told about somebody dying, that can trip us up as a trauma and make us kind of fearful of answering the phone, for example. So if we can really empower ourselves and those around us to
这意味着创伤元素会被平息，这样我们在思考它们时就不会被绊倒。然后我们剩下的就只是悲伤的元素，我的许多客户告诉我，他们觉得这些元素还可以。实际上，他们想要抓住悲伤不放。他们不想抓住创伤不放。如果你在突然的情况下失去了父母，你甚至可能当时就在现场。你可能目睹了这一切。你可能不得不参与心肺复苏（CPR），或者目睹了某人病情变得非常严重。所有这些事情本身都可能是创伤性的。有时，甚至是我们被告知某人去世的方式，都会作为一种创伤绊倒我们，例如让我们对接电话感到恐惧。因此，如果我们能够真正赋予我们自己和周围的人力量，
really think about accessing treatment or therapy is not going to make you forget the person. It's not going to make you stop loving them. But if it helps you to live with a life where you are less dominated and consumed by pain that makes each day feel impossible, then it's absolutely worth doing. And then you're free to just navigate the grief. So let's just really be clear, what is grief and what is trauma? Because it might feel like it's all one in the same thing. But actually, if you find yourself going back to key moments that feel extra specially poignant and painful, that could be a key indication that's trauma.
真正认识到接受治疗或心理辅导不会让你忘记这个人。它不会让你停止爱他们。但如果它能帮助你过上一种不再被痛苦主导和吞噬的生活，让每一天看起来都不那么难以忍受，那么它绝对值得去做。然后你就可以自由地去经历悲伤了。所以让我们明确一点，什么是悲伤，什么是创伤？因为你可能会觉得它们完全是一回事。但实际上，如果你发现自己不断回到那些格外感人、痛苦的时刻，这可能就是创伤的一个关键迹象。
And you don't always need to feel that level of intensity about that. And that can be changed. It's really interesting you say that, because I think, like, from my own personal experience and from individuals that I've spoken to in the past, is a lot of people give up sometimes once they've had one round of you know counseling for example or giving something to go to try and help with what they perceive is the problem behind losing a parent so my advice is always don't give up if something doesn't work the first time round take a
你并不总是需要对那件事感到那种程度的强烈情绪。而且这是可以改变的。你这么说真的很有趣，因为我认为，从我自己的个人经历以及我过去交流过的人来看，很多人在经历过一轮咨询（比如去尝试解决他们认为失去父母背后的问题）后有时就会放弃，所以我的建议永远是：如果第一次没有奏效，不要放弃，退后
step back and try and work out what could help. Because like you say, you might be going to address problem A, but it's not actually problem A, that's the problem, it's problem B. And this is really, really interesting, you say that about you differentiate between different things that can happen in one moment. And I guess, Harry, just something that came into my mind when you were just speaking there, sometimes you might not be ready for it. So we've had situations sometimes where someone might reach out and their parent may have died a couple days ago. And sometimes you're not ready to actually really speak about that grief. And that's okay. But my story is a
一步，努力找出什么才是有帮助的。因为就像你说的，你可能去解决问题A，但实际上它不是问题A，问题才是问题B，而是问题B。你刚才说到一个人在同一时刻可能发生的不同事情之间的区别，这真的非常非常有趣。哈里，我想起一个问题，刚才你在说话的时候突然冒出来的，有时候你可能还没准备好。所以有时我们会遇到这种情况，有人可能会寻求帮助，而他们的父母可能几天前刚去世。有时候你还没准备好真正谈论这种悲伤。没关系。但我的故事有点
little bit different because I remember when my mom died, went to university, had fun as I've mentioned before and then I tried some facilities at the university and went to one counseling session and was like this is not for me, never again and just gave up there and it was only years later that I thought, actually, let me see what this is about. And it actually did help. So I think everybody will, if you feel like you need services and help, it's when you're ready.
不同，因为我记得我妈妈去世时，我去上大学，正如我之前提到的那样玩得很开心，然后我尝试了大学的一些设施，去进行了一次咨询，然后觉得这不适合我，再也不去了，就在那里放弃了。直到多年后我才想，其实，让我看看这到底是怎么回事。它确实起作用了。所以我觉得每个人——如果你觉得你需要服务和帮助，那是在你准备好的时候。
And don't let anyone tell you you're ready. You have to be ready yourself to get that help. A lot of what people give up sometimes is they don't really build a rapport with the other person on the other side of the table. And again, don't label the whole industry based on the fact that you couldn't build a rapport with one person because if you went again that rapport might get built and then it's completely different experience. These are individuals at the end of the day and they have personalities and you will click with one,
不要让任何人告诉你你准备好了。你必须自己准备好去获得这种帮助。很多人之所以有时会放弃，是因为他们并没有真正与坐在桌子对面的人建立融洽的关系。同样，不要因为你无法与某一个人建立融洽的关系，就把整个行业都贴上标签，因为如果你再去一次，这种融洽关系可能会建立起来，然后就会是完全不同的体验。归根结底，这些人都是独立的个体，他们有各自的性格，你会和一个
you won't click with the other. And if you do it first time, amazing, great, efficient. If you don't do it first time, you could do it the second time. Don't leave that as an unanswered question. Keep going, but again, take your time. You might wanna break, refresh, but just don't give up give up and you deserve that you deserve not to have one round the one round didn't work you deserve to get a second round if that doesn't work you
人合得来，跟另一个人合不来。如果你第一次就成功了，那太棒了，非常好，很高效。如果你第一次没成功，你可以在第二次再试。不要把它留下作为一个没有答案的问题。继续坚持，但同样，放慢节奏。你可能想要休息、恢复一下，但千万不要放弃。你值得拥有这一切，你值得在第一轮没成功时获得第二轮，如果那次还不成功，你
deserve it you keep going back until you've built that report and you're getting the outputs of what they're there for to help people on their journey. Absolutely so very important important. Thanks for that reminder. So let's hear a little bit about It's Time charity. What is it, how did it come about and what do you offer? It's Time charity and Harry, I think you touched on it a little bit earlier. Back in, and I don't know the dates,
值得一直坚持下去，直到你们建立起默契，并获得他们来到这里的初衷——即帮助人们走过人生旅程——所带来的成果。绝对如此，非常重要。谢谢你的提醒。那么让我们来了解一下“It's Time”慈善机构。它是什么，它是如何创立的，你们提供什么？“It's Time”慈善机构，哈里，我想你刚才稍微提到过了一点。早在，我不记得具体日期了，
but let's say the early 2010 sometime, you probably know the date, Harry. We identified that there was a gap in the market for people that have lost a parent between roughly the ages of 16 to 30. And it was that those individuals may not necessarily have the help in society. And so the charity was founded by a group of trustees. But essentially, we offer support to people that are in that category who have lost a parent. We offer a community, so we run things like walk and talk and meet and greet, which are essentially ones online ones walk in and essentially it's a base
但我们假设是在2010年代初期左右吧，你可能知道具体日期，哈里。我们发现市场上有个空白，针对那些年龄在大约16到30岁之间失去了父母的人。这群人在社会上可能未必能得到相应的帮助。于是，这个慈善机构由一群受托人创立了。但本质上，我们为处于该类别且失去了父母的人提供支持。我们提供一个社区，所以我们举办诸如散步交谈、见面会等活动，这些本质上既有线上活动也有线下散步，基本上它是一个
for people to meet up and really talk about their grief and really relate to people that are going through something similar. We also have a walk in memory as well. So every year we do a walk in memory, you can walk for the person that you've lost. We help businesses write some of I guess their documents which can help people with grief and also charity aspects as well. So we do a lot of fundraising as well and also clinical therapy as well. We offer that a lot of fundraising as well and also clinical therapy as well. We offer that as well but in groups. We are looking to start doing individual but that will come hopefully soon. I guess Harry anything else you wanted to add? No you nailed that. I just think that the charity over the last few years of its existence has grown.
供人们聚在一起真正谈论他们的悲伤，并与那些正在经历类似事情的人建立共鸣的基地。我们还有一个“记忆漫步”活动。所以每年我们都会举办一次记忆漫步，你可以为你失去的那个人而走。我们帮助企业编写一些文件，这些文件可以帮助人们应对悲伤，同时也涉及慈善方面的工作。所以我们做了很多筹款工作，还有临床治疗。我们提供了很多筹款，还有临床治疗。我们提供这种服务，但以小组形式。我们正考虑开展个人治疗，希望不久后能实现。哈里，我想问你还有什么想补充的吗？不，你讲得太棒了。我只是觉得这个慈善机构在其存在的过去几年里一直在不断成长。
I'm really, really proud as a trustee to see it grow over the four years. But the reason why it's grown is because we put the people in our community first and we bring them also to the table. So we have volunteers who take up positions in the charity to help grow certain pillars of it, such as the DE&IBIT, marketing, the branding and corporate fundraisings. We then have an advisory panel who are all volunteers who have again a seat at the table and help us inform our strategy, the direction we want to go, tactics that we can put into place, products and services. We try and all work together to move it all in the right direction. And it is really, really, as I said, super proud to have seen where it's grown and the community that we've
作为一名受托人，看到它在四年里不断发展壮大，我感到非常非常自豪。但它之所以能成长，是因为我们将社区里的人放在第一位，我们也把他们带到决策桌前。所以我们有志愿者在慈善机构担任职位，帮助发展它的某些支柱，比如DE&I（多元、公平与包容）、市场营销、品牌建设和企业筹款。然后我们还有一个顾问委员会，全由志愿者组成，他们同样在决策桌上拥有一席之地，帮助我们完善战略、我们想要发展的方向、我们可以实施的策略、产品和我们提供的服务。我们努力共同努力，朝着正确的方向推动它发展。正如我所说，看到它的成长以及我们建立的
built and there's options for everyone. Like I said, if someone wants to just like that Instagram photo and feel a part of it, they can do. People want to get involved and help grow and focus on certain things, host certain things, do things in their local area, they can. I feel we are a bit of a blank canvas where we can do anything within reason and we're not rigid to doing this and this and that's what's really exciting about us and the future is exciting. I'm really, really proud of the team we have as well and all the trustees and the staff members that we have to who work on the charity day in day out and whip us into shape when they need us. One thing I was just going to add is over the last let's say two years we've really grown through our social media platforms and one thing that has really resonated and
社区，我真的、真的感到超级自豪，每个人都有适合自己的选择。就像我说的，如果有人只想点赞那个Instagram照片并感觉自己是其中的一部分，他们可以这样做。如果人们想参与进来、帮助成长并专注于某些事情、主持某些活动、在当地做一些事情，他们也可以。我觉得我们有点像一张白纸，在合理范围内我们可以做任何事情，我们并不死板地只做这个或那个，这就是我们真正令人兴奋的地方，未来也令人兴奋。对于我们拥有的团队以及所有日复一日为慈善机构工作的受托人和工作人员，以及在我们需要时帮我们走上正轨的伙伴们，我也感到非常非常自豪。我正要补充的一点是，在过去的两年左右里，我们通过我们的社交媒体平台真正成长起来了，有一件事真正引起了共鸣，并且
which I didn't really anticipate was how many people were actually impacted and how many people are actually going through this within the UK and it's rather it's it's really nice to see that the charity is helping these individuals find a safe space to discuss their grief and to meet people that are going through similar things. And hopefully we continue to grow as much as we have been. Thank you. What are your social media handles and where do you hang out and what's your website? The website which you can find us and all the information is at www.itstimecharity.co.uk. Similarly, you've got the Instagram handle, It's Time charity, and TikTok as well, which has been growing
这是我没有预料到的，那就是有多少人实际上受到了影响，有多少人实际上正在经历这一切。在英国，很高兴看到慈善机构正在帮助这些个体找到一个安全的空间来讨论他们的悲伤，并结识正在经历类似事情的人。希望我们能像以前一样继续成长。谢谢。你们的社交媒体账号是什么？你们经常活跃在哪里？你们的网站是什么？你们可以找到我们的网站以及所有信息的网址是：www.itstimecharity.co.uk。同样，你们还可以在Instagram上找到我们，账号是 It's Time charity，还有TikTok，它也一直在
as well. So those are the three main channels. Actually, I lie, we've also got LinkedIn, where you'll be able to find us on It's Time charity, which we are quite vocal in there as well. Amazing. Thank you. I love LinkedIn. It's my guilty pleasure. Thank you so much for your time, both of you, and for talking about something that I know is emotional, but it's so important. And kudos to you guys for doing what you do with It's Time because, yeah, it really does validate people. And like you say, there's not anything else out there, you know, that's similar. You guys are it. So if people want to donate money, can they do that via your website as well?
不断增长。所以这就是三个主要的渠道。其实我撒谎了，我们还有领英（LinkedIn），你也可以在上面找到我们，账号是 It's Time charity，我们在那里也相当活跃。太棒了。谢谢。我喜欢领英。这是我的一大私密爱好。非常感谢你们俩抽出时间，谈论这个我知道充满情感但又非常重要的话题。向你们致敬，感谢你们通过“It's Time”所做的事情，因为，是的，它确实赋予了人们认同感。就像你们说的，外面真的没有其他类似的东西了，你们就是独一无二的。所以如果人们想要捐款，他们也可以通过你们的网站吗？
Yes, there's a direct link. You can click through and can donate. Great. Thank you so much for your time. Wishing you well with your impending nuptials, Hannah, and with everything that comes with you, Harry. Thank you very much. It's a pleasure to be here. Really, really appreciate it. It was lovely talking. Amazing. No, thank you very much and really appreciate it speaking today with you. Thank you. Thank you so much for your time in watching this episode and to Harry and Hannah for speaking with us. If you do rate this episode
是的，有一个直接链接。你可以点击跳转并进行捐赠。太棒了。非常感谢你们抽出时间。汉娜，祝你即将到来的婚礼一切顺利，哈里，祝你一切都好。非常感谢。很高兴能来到这里。真的非常感激。这次谈话非常愉快。太棒了。不，非常感谢，非常感激今天能与你们交谈。谢谢。非常感谢你们抽出时间观看这一集，也感谢哈里和汉娜与我们交谈。如果你给这一集评分，
it would mean the world if you would like it, if you would subscribe, if you'd follow the show, if you drop a comment let's start a wave of compassion in the comments on YouTube if this resonates with you because you have lost a parent in your young adulthood. I would love it if you would let us know and let us know if we've hit the mark for you today or if you think there's other areas we should have and could have covered. Please do go along and give the guys at It's Time charity a follow on TikTok and on LinkedIn and on Instagram and do check out their website. If you've got any spare money and you'd like to support the cause, please do. If you would like to feel supported in your grief, don't forget there's also the Grief Collective
如果你能点赞、订阅、关注这个节目、留下评论，那对我们意义重大。如果这引发了你的共鸣，因为你在青年时期失去了父母，让我们在YouTube的评论区里掀起一股同理心浪潮吧。如果你能让我们知道，并让我们知道我们今天是否切中了要害，或者你认为还有哪些其他领域我们应该且本可以涵盖，我会非常感激。请务必在TikTok、领英和Instagram上关注“It's Time”慈善机构的伙伴们，并去看看他们的网站。如果你有任何闲钱并想支持这项事业，请务必这样做。如果你想在悲伤中感受到支持，别忘了还有《悲伤合集》
book which gets wonderful reviews and really does help expand these conversations on grief too. If you rate any creator anywhere, the kindest thing you can do for free is to subscribe or follow their show. So please, if you do enjoy this content, please do consider doing that for me now. With this podcast that you'll sign, you'll be on your way to being qualified It's the Aspiring Psychologist Podcast With Dr. Mary Entret There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
这本书获得了极佳的评价，并且确实有助于进一步扩大关于悲伤的这些对话。如果你在任何地方给任何创作者评分，你能免费做的最善良的事情就是订阅或关注他们的节目。所以，如果你确实喜欢这个内容，现在请考虑为我这样做。通过这个你将签署的播客，你将迈向成为一名合格的心理学家的道路。这就是由玛丽·昂特雷特博士主持的《有抱负的心理学家播客》。本集还没有评论。点击文稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。